de manera oficial los que fueron líderes
de la antigua guerrilla de las farc
reconocieron su responsabilidad en los
secuestros de civiles y militares
durante el conflicto armado en colombia
grande encuentra una representación lo
hicieron frente a la jurisdicción
especial para la paz que acusa a ocho de
los jefes de las farc de crímenes de
lesa humanidad y de guerra comenzamos
nosotros haciendo la reafirmación de
nuestro reconocimiento de
responsabilidad en lo que fue la
política de secuestros desarrollada por
las farc ep haciendo también un
reconocimiento explícito del sufrimiento
infringido de manera injustificable a
las víctimas no solamente que fueron
retenidas sino también a sus familias a
sus amigos por supuesto también el daño
que esto causó al conjunto de la
sociedad colombiana
es un paso aplaudido por la onu hacia la
justicia para las víctimas y el
compromiso de los exguerrilleros con el
acuerdo de paz
las investigaciones de la jurisdicción
de paz acreditan más de 2.100 víctimas
de secuestros
los líderes de las farc se
comprometieron también a localizar los
cuerpos de 100 personas secuestradas y
ejecutadas desaparecidas desde entonces
ahora la jurisdicción especial deberá
revisar las versiones de los antiguos
guerrilleros y decidirse el
reconocimiento de sus crímenes es
sincero y aporta a la verdad sobre el
conflicto armado de ser así recibirán
condenas menores y enfocadas a reparar
el daño causado si el tribunal considera
que los dos guerrilleros no asumen su
responsabilidad podrían ser condenados
hasta con 20 años de cárcel